Salut !
En septembre 2020,
j'ai fait ici même, un gros sujet
sur ce qu'était l'échec, la réussite.
En faisant appel au parcours
de plusieurs intervenants.
Dans ce deuxième épisode,
j'avais envie que nous parlions
ensemble de la passion.
Pas le fruit de la passion,
pas la passion amoureuse,
mais bien la préférence
pour une activité.
Le penchant pour quelque chose,
l'appétence dans un domaine, le kiffe.
Mais la passion, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Est-ce qu'on doit déjà
obligatoirement en avoir une ?
J'ai pas eu l'idée
d'explorer ce thème tout seul,
j'ai pu voir récemment le film Soul,
qui aborde des sujets très matures
d'ailleurs, pour un film d'animation.
Ce qui donne un double
niveau de lecture
pour les adultes et les enfants,
quand on le regarde.
Le thème principal est central,
c'est évidemment la passion
au travers de Joe Gartner.
Je vous laisse le plaisir de regarder
ces quelques secondes d'extrait,
vous allez vite comprendre.
La musique, il n'y a que ça
qui compte pour moi.
Dès je me réveille le matin
et que je sors de mon lit.
Je ne pense qu'à ça !
En streaming à Noël sur Disney +.
- C'est quoi cet endroit ?
- C'est le grand avant.
- Je crois que j'ai rien à faire ici.
- A noël.
- La musique, c'est la vie.
- Célébrez.
- Il faut savoir écouter.
- Les bonheurs de la vie.
- Sois prêt, ta vie va commencer.
Soul, des Studios Disney Pixar.
- Soul ! Mais qu'est ce qu'il t'arrive,
t'as le diable au corps ?
- De quoi je me mêle ?
- Cougar !
- C'est pourquoi,
quand Disney m'a proposé
de rendre hommage
à l'introspection de Joe et de 22,
en proposant ce deuxième épisode
en axant la thématique sur la passion.
J'étais plus que ravi.
Vous avez compris,
le rêve ultime de Joe,
c'est de jouer dans un club.
Il est profondément
passionné par la musique.
Et de cette passion,
sont nés des rêves.
Le rêve d'en vivre, le rêve d'en jouer
dans des lieux très spécifiques.
Et pour tout ça, il va devoir comprendre
en profondeur sa propre passion.
Pourquoi elle est née,
pourquoi elle existe ?
Comment elle s'intègre dans sa vie,
et quels sont les sacrifices aussi,
qu'il est prêt à faire.
En gros, quel obstacle il est prêt
à surmonter pour sa passion.
Le film Soul est disponible depuis
le 25 décembre en streaming,
exclusivement sur Disney +.
Vous trouverez le lien
dans la description.
Vous allez adorer.
Maintenant nous allons découvrir,
comment la passion
s'ancre dans notre cerveau.
Nous allons aussi
parler avec des personnes
que vous connaissez très bien.
Bernard Werber, un des auteurs français
les plus lus dans le monde.
Pierre Croce, qui réalise des vidéos
de divertissement depuis des années.
Benjamin Verrecchia,
qui réalise des vidéos d'humour,
mais aussi de cuisine.
Lola Dubini, présente
dans beaucoup de domaines
avec la musique
comme socle commun.
PADG, voix-off de nombreux
films, séries,  jeux vidéos,
dessins animés, publicités.
Et Natoo, qui a créé un univers
allant de la vidéo au livre,
en passant par les jeux de société.
Vous les connaissez pour une activité
qui me semble être leur passion visible.
Mais est-ce que c'est vraiment
leur passion profonde ?
Comment vivent-ils
leur passion au quotidien ?
Comment les ont-ils découvertes ?
D'ailleurs, est-ce qu'on peut
se lasser d'une passion ?
Vous voyez que rapidement,
ce thème est bien plus complexe
que ce qu'il n'y paraît.
Et c'est ce que j'ai découvert
en discutant avec eux.
Alors si vous cherchez
votre passion dans la vie,
ou si vous vous demandez comment vous
devriez gérer celle que vous avez déjà.
Cette vidéo devrait vous passionner.
Je m'appelle Fabien Olicard,
j'ai toujours agi
par passion du mentalisme.
Ou du moins, c'est ce que je crois.
Quand on pense au mot passion,
on a tout de suite la vision
d'un acte matérialisé,
en général d'un sport, ou quelque chose
de ludique voire de créatif.
Mais si je réfléchis à ma propre
passion pour le cerveau,
je me dis :
est-ce qu'elle aurait pu s'exprimer
par autre chose que le mentalisme ?
La définition de passion selon
le dictionnaire Larousse, est la suivante :
Mouvement affectif très vif
qui s'empare de quelqu'un
en lui faisant prendre parti violemment
pour ou contre quelque chose.
Ou encore penchant vif et persistant,
comme si on pouvait pas lutter
contre ce désir de
quelque chose, de quelqu'un.
Pourtant, j'ai vraiment l'impression
que chacun définit la passion
selon le filtre de sa propre vie.
- La passion, c'est l'amour.
C'est l'amour de quelqu'un,
de quelque chose,
d'une curiosité qui devient
un coup de foudre, l'amour.
- Alors je dirais qu'une passion,
c'est une activité dont
tu peux pas te passer.
Tu as envie de la faire,
si tu ne la fais pas ça te démange.
Et peu importe le temps
que ça va te prendre,
peu importe le temps
que tu vas investir dedans,
c'est pas un problème.
Au moment où j'ai commencé
à faire des vidéos,
j'ai senti que j'adorais écrire,
créer, filmer, tourner des vidéos,
raconter des histoires en fait.
- Pour moi la passion est reliée
à la notion de joie.
J'ai de la joie quand
je fabrique des mondes,
j'ai eu de la joie quand
je raconte des histoires,
j'ai de la joie quand
j'en écoute qui me font rêver.
- Une passion
au sens commun, selon moi,
c'est quelque chose
qui est dans notre ventre
et qui nous fait vivre
encore plus intensément notre vie.
- Quand tu passes du temps
sur quelque chose
et que tu considères
que sur d'autres sujets,
ce serait du temps
compliqué à passer.
Et la passion du coup, ça devient...
Travailler avec passion,
c'est à dire que tu te rends pas compte
que tu passes du temps à ça
et que ton temps passe très vite.
- Peu importe la Ferrari que tu veux.
Peu importe le château que tu veux.
Et tu as tout à fait
le droit de le vouloir.
Quel va être le moteur de ça ?
De ta fusée ?
Tu peux faire tout ce que tu veux,
s'il n'y a pas d'essence
pour faire décoller l'histoire,
tu ne peux rien faire.
On peut le prendre en essence
pour aller dans la Ferrari,
mais dans l'essence,
quelle est mon essence ?
- On sent à travers ces réponses,
que la passion
organiserait une sorte de déséquilibre
émotionnel ou psychologique.
Par modification
de nos perceptions déjà,
comme le temps qui ne compte plus
quand on est dans sa passion.
Ou par la naissance
d'une sorte d'obsession.
Alors on reconnaît une passion réelle
par le fait qu'elle nous obsède ?
- La vraie passion,
je pense que c'est l'obsession
dans le bon sens du terme.
C'est-à-dire que le joueur de guitare,
il va être je pense obsédé par une mélodie,
par son envie de réussir une gamme.
Voilà, de jouer un tel morceau
à la perfection.
Et donc c'est une obsession
du bien fait, de bien faire.
Un peintre, je pense qu'il est obsédé,
il est passionné par ses couleurs,
par le rendu qu'il veut sur un tableau.
Mais c'est pas une...
Quoique, oui ça peut être
une obsession qui peut le détruire aussi.
Mais quand elle est passionnée,
je pense qu'elle est plutôt positive.
- Ta passion c'est un exhausteur
de tous les sentiments
qui puissent exister
sur cette planète.
C'est-à-dire, quand je chante,
je peux être en colère.
Et j'ai le droit.
Quand je chante,
je peux être hyper émue.
je peux être sensuelle.
Tu vois, il y a pleins d'émotions et
tu peux passer par toutes les émotions.
Quand on te connaît par ta passion,
c'est une carte d'identité différente.
Qui complète la personne
que tu es dans la vie.
C'est vraiment pour moi,
deux choses indissociables.
Moi, si tu me connais moi,
il faudra que tu me connaisse
un moment par ma passion.
Parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'on se connaît pas à 100%.
- Je trouve que la vraie passion,
pour le coup, c'est quand
tu en parles avec des gens
et que tu te rends compte
que tu défends pas ce sujet là,
comme tu défends d'autres sujets.
A partir du moment où tu te dis :
Là je suis en train
vraiment de parler avec le cœur
et je peux en parler pendant des heures,
et j'ai des vrais arguments,
et j'ai des vraies convictions
par rapport à ça.
Là tu touches au point
sensible d'une passion.
Moi, je peux parler pleins de sujets.
Mais je sais les 5-10 sujets
où je vais en parler
et je vais pas prendre ça à la légère.
J'en parle avec des arguments,
avec une façon de penser.
- La passion est donc identifiée par
des émotions fortes liées à un sujet.
C'est intéressant car on constate,
que ça globalise bien plus que
le simple plaisir de faire une activité.
Parler de cette activité ou de ce sujet
n'est alors jamais anodin.
On peut y voir quand même beaucoup
de similitudes avec l'amour.
Car dans tous ces cas, le cerveau
va produire de la dopamine
qui provoque l'euphorie
et de l'adrénaline
et de la noradrénaline,
qui peuvent provoquer des insomnies.
Mais honnêtement,
ma passion pour le mentalisme
ne m'empêche pas vraiment de dormir.
Mais peut provoquer, c'est vrai,
des états d'euphorie.
D'ailleurs,
je me lasse pas de ce sujet.
Alors, est-ce que c'est vraiment
une grande passion, ma grande passion ?
Dans le but de comparer,
j'ai demandé à mes invités
de me parler de leur passion
et du moment où ils pensent
qu'elle s'est déclenchée chez eux.
Comment elle a pu naître d'un coup ?
- Les plus grands plaisir que
j'ai eu dans la vie auront été issues,
soit du fait d'écouter des histoires,
soit du fait de fabriquer des mondes
dans lequel j'ai pu moi-même
construire des histoires.
- Ma passion n'est pas
exactement les voix.
C'est peut-être d'essayer d'être le plus
conscient possible dans ce que je fais.
ça c'est hyper important chez moi,
c'est-à-dire, instant après instant.
Qu'est-ce que je suis
en train de penser ?
en train de recevoir ?
Qu'est-ce que je suis en train
de mettre dans mes émotions
et dans ma dynamique de créativité ?
Et évidemment, ça passe par les voix.
Mais pas seulement.
C'est à partir de ça,
ou avec le filtre des voix,
que je vais plutôt essayer
d'aller dans la réalisation,
peut-être de l'être humain
qu'on est soi-même.
Et en tout cas moi,
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire.
Et franchement, je suis
très très très passionné de ça.
- J'ai toujours aimé la musique.
Et moi la musique,
c'est ce qui maintenant, j'ai 27 ans.
Ce qui a 27 ans, me fait vivre à 100 %
toutes les émotions rassemblées en fait.
En fait un jour, j'ai senti que
je chantais un peu différemment
des autres en cours de musique.
Et ça a été quand
quelqu'un d'autre m'a identifiée comme,
ça c'est pas normal
ce qui se passe chez elle.
Et c'était mon prof de musique qui a
convoqué mes parents, en disant :
"La voix de Lola,
je l'ai jamais entendue.
Et ça fait 20 ans que je suis prof.
Je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose à faire".
Et je me suis dit :
Ah mais moi
je me le disais toute seule,
mais franchement je n'osais pas
me sentir un peu spéciale,
parce que en soit, avoir une passion
c'est aussi sentir spéciale.
Et le vrai, vrai, vrai déclic en moi,
qui m'a montré que
la musique c'était viscéral.
C'est que j'arrivais à chanter
les chansons des autres.
J'ai compris que ma passion
prenait vie en moi,
quand je me suis dit que même
les mots des autres pouvaient m'aller,
pour exprimer un sentiment.
Et que je ne pouvais pas
le parler en fait.
J'étais obligée de le chanter.
- J'ai l'impression quand
je regarde un peu à travers
tout ce que j'ai fait sur les dix
dernières années ou plus.
J'ai l'impression que ça a toujours été
ma seule vraie passion commune à tout,
ça a été de créer.
A chaque fois que
je vais aller dans un domaine,
je veux essayer d'être un peu original,
de casser un peu les codes.
Donc de les apprendre
et ensuite de les déstructurer.
- Moi je pense que je suis passionnée
par le fait de raconter des histoires.
Je peux passer beaucoup de temps
à écrire un scénario.
Avec des amis on se réunit,
on prend du temps.
C'est assez professionnel du coup,
parce que c'est quand même
des heures de réunion.
Mais en fait j'ai du mal justement,
à dire que mon métier.
Ce que je fais actuellement,
c'est un vrai travail.
Parce que depuis dix ans,
ça reste une passion avant tout.
Donc c'est vrai
qu'il y a aussi cette phase,
où ensuite on va filmer.
C'est pas toujours évident en vrai,
quand tu as des heures de tournage.
ça peut prendre un temps fou,
il y a des problèmes techniques.
Il y a pleins de choses
qui peuvent t'agacer,
qui se déroulent pas comme prévu.
Mais tu t'accroches, tu lâches pas,
tu jettes pas l'éponge.
Parce que tu veux aller
au bout de ton projet.
- Je suis passionné
d'histoire par exemple.
Je suis passionné de bouffe.
Je suis passionné des gens,
j'adore les gens,
je me nourris de biographies.
Qu'on me raconte la guerre de Troie,
ou qu'un type me raconte
ses vacances en Islande.
Je suis passionné.
Alors après, il y a la différence
entre passionné et expert aussi.
On croit souvent que
la passion amène forcément
la connaissance ultime de son sujet,
alors qu'en fait pas du tout.
ça peut être, je suis passionné,
j'ai encore 10 000 choses à apprendre.
Mais quand je me retrouve
dans ce que je fais,
En fait quand je suis moi-même,
et quand je suis aligné
sur ce que je fais.
Et sur mon sujet
sur la passion du truc.
C'est pour ça que quand je dis
que je suis passionné d'histoire,
ça veut pas dire que je vais manger
18 bouquins sur Jules César.
ça veut juste dire que
dès qu'il y a un sujet,
je prends Jules César,
c'est un exemple.
Sur la Rome antique
ou sur la Grèce antique.
ça va forcément m'intéresser.
En fait, je suis en train d'essayer
de faire la différence entre,
je suis intéressé, je suis curieux
et je suis passionné de.
- Benjamin vient de mettre le doigt
sur quelque chose de primordial.
La frontière est très faible
entre ce qui nous intéresse,
ce qui nous rend curieux
et ce qui nous passionne.
La différence, c'est la charge
et la puissance de nos émotions.
Comme nous l'avons
entendu tout à l'heure.
Mais quelque chose m'interpelle.
Si la définition de chacun
du mot passion était un peu vague,
voire très subjective.
Je suis surpris qu'aucune
de ces personnes n'arrivent à décrire
leurs propres passions en une phrase
hyper simple et hyper claire.
Et pourtant moi aussi,
je serais incapable de le faire.
On reviendra sur ce point
dans la troisième partie,
qui cache des choses
vraiment fascinantes.
Pour le moment,
je reste sur mes invités
et je les crois tous passionnés
et je les ai invités pour ça
et pour leur pertinence.
Mais est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment vivre sans passion ?
C'est vrai qu'il existe
une sorte de pression sociale
qui nous oblige à avoir une passion.
Comme si on n'était pas
entièrement défini,
si on ne savait pas exprimer
ce qui nous plaît le plus dans la vie.
Et cette pression
elle peut être directe.
Par exemple des parents,
qui veulent que leurs enfants
fassent absolument une activité.
Ou indirecte, comme par exemple,
si on se sent un peu nul,
un peu à l'écart parce qu'on voit
les autres s'épanouir dans une activité,
alors que nous,
on a pas quelque chose
qui nous fait vraiment vibrer.
Mais est-ce que c'est
simplement sociétal
ou est-ce que c'est vraiment
un problème majeur
de ne pas avoir
de passion dans sa vie ?
- J'ai une de mes sœurs qui
me dit souvent, j'ai pas de passion.
Et qui m'envie.
Qui est envieuse de ma passion.
Sauf que s'il y a des gens
qui sont dans cette situation
et qui regardent la vidéo, il faut...
Je dis pas que
c'est la bonne manière de faire,
mais j'aimerais que
vous puissiez vous dire
que ce qui va me faire du bien à moi
ne vous fera pas de bien à vous.
Et du coup, ne soyez pas
envieux de quelque chose
qui ne vous apaisera pas.
Ne cherchez pas la passion des gens,
cherchez ce qui vous passionne
vous très profondément.
Et il n'y a pas de passion honteuse.
C'est-à-dire que si c'est la philatélie
et les timbres qui vous apaisent
et qui vous stabilisent,
ce n'est pas une honte.
Il n'y a pas de passion pourrie.
Il y a que quelque chose
qui répond à un besoin vital.
Ecoutez vous et laissez vous aller.
Sincèrement.
- Devenir passionné de quelque chose,
c'est d'être conscient qu'on est
passionné de quelque chose.
Les gens qui disent,
je n'ai aucune passion dans la vie.
Il a peut-être la passion de rien foutre.
En fait, on est tous
passionnés de quelque chose.
Qu'est ce que c'est quelqu'un
qui n'aurait pas de passion,
si on peut partager ça.
Je pense que c'est pas possible
de vivre sans passion.
Pour découvrir des mondes,
vous devez sortir du port.
S'éloigner des rivages,
s'éloigner des gens qu'on aime parfois.
Et être sur cette mer
ou cet océan de la vie
avec un gouvernail et des voiles.
Et vous pouvez pas contrôler
cet océan, c'est impossible,
c'est impossible de contrôler l'océan.
Par contre vous pouvez
vous laisser aller dans la tempête,
et il se peut que vous mourriez.
Mais si vous n'êtes pas parti du port,
vous pouvez pas découvrir votre
Amérique comme Christophe Colomb.
- Je pense qu'il y a plein de personnes
qui n'ont pas forcément de passion
et c'est pas grave.
Peut-être qu'il y a des gens,
qui après une dure journée de boulot
sont très heureux juste de se poser,
de regarder un film,
partager des moments
avec leur famille.
Et c'est pas très grave,
il faut de tout.
Après je pense que
si personne n'avait de passion,
on vivrait dans un monde où il y aurait
forcément un peu moins d'art,
Il y aurait moins de peinture,
moins de théâtre, moins de chanson.
Est-ce qu'une passion aussi,
c'est vraiment une activité artistique,
ou passionné d'automobile
ou d'un truc matériel ?
ça se trouve aussi, tu peux être
passionné juste par des gens.
Tu peux être passionné par
ta famille et la communication.
J'ai des amis, je ne comprends pas
comment ils font.
Ils peuvent vraiment
t'écouter pendant des heures
et aimer résoudre tes problèmes.
- Quand quelqu'un te dis je rêve pas.
C'est juste qu'il n'en a pas conscience.
On est obligé de rêver,
le rêve fait partie
du fonctionnement du cerveau.
C'est juste qu'il n'y porte
pas forcément d'intérêt.
Il ne se réveille pas
en essayant d'y repenser, etc.
Donc un rêve, tu l'oublies au bout de
quelques heures dans la journée
voire même quelques minutes.
Et la passion c'est
peut-être ça aussi, c'est ce côté,
je me rends pas compte qu'en fait
je passe beaucoup de temps à faire ça,
et je considère pas que ça
peut être une passion pour quelqu'un.
Donc quand on me demande,
est-ce que c'est une passion,
je vais pas dire
je suis passionné par ça
parce que c'est nul
entre guillemets.
Mais au final pour lui, c'est une passion
et c'est pas plus mal.
C'est ce que je disais au début,
s'il considère que ce temps,
c'est pas du temps de perdu
ou pas du temps laborieux.
Au final c'est une passion,
c'est quelque chose
qui lui fait passer du temps plaisant.
Sans s'en rendre compte.
- Alors j'aime pas le mot passion,
parce que ça vient de Pathos
qui est la douleur.
ça a donné pathétique.
Je préférerais le mot enthousiaste.
Est-ce qu'une vie sans enthousiasme
vaut la peine d'être vécue,
voilà une bonne question.
Passion, quand j'entends ce mot là,
je pense à ces gens
passionnément amoureux.
Donc on sait déjà
que ça va mal finir.
Ces gens passionnément dans le jeu,
on sait que ça va mal finir.
Moi j'aime bien cette idée d'enthousiasme
liée à la notion de talent.
On a tous un talent particulier,
au moment où on le découvre,
au moment où on l'exprime,
on se retrouve dans une certaine joie.
- Je voulais rajouter aussi,
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui peuvent pas culpabiliser,
mais complexer
de ne pas avoir de passion.
C'est un truc, chez les jeunes
qui revient, c'est le côté :
"Bah moi j'ai pas de passion".
Sous-entendu, il y a un espèce de
rabaissement de confiance en soi,
parce qu'on aurait pas de passion.
C'est pas un truc
qu'on doit forcément avoir
comme ça en un
claquement de doigts.
Et ça se crée.
ça se crée par les rencontres,
par la curiosité.
Et voilà, ne surtout pas culpabiliser
de ne pas avoir de passion.
Parce que peut-être qu'on en a une,
mais on l'a pas conscientisée.
Et que ça peut être n'importe quoi.
ça ne doit pas être la passion
qui est en vogue actuelle,
ou la passion que mes parents
veulent absolument que j'aie, etc.
ça peut être, ça va se décanter, voilà.
Pour ajouter qu'il y a zéro complexe
de ne pas avoir de passion maintenant.
C'est très épanouissant,
c'est ce qui peut nous définir
sur le long terme
dans une vie, une passion.
Mais no stress,
si elle n'est pas décidée.
Si elle n'est pas en éclosion
quand on est jeune.
- Si on prend la réflexion
de Bernard Werber,
on peut dès lors admettre
qu'une vie sans passion, c'est possible.
Mais pas une vie sans enthousiasme.
Et c'est différent,
moi j'aime beaucoup ce parallèle.
En prenant le substantif passion,
pour nommer un centre d'intérêt
qui nous fait vibrer.
On idéalise complètement
le fait d'en avoir une.
Mais l'état que l'on appelle passion
est un état tellement fort,
qu'il peut dominer le mental.
En ça, nommer un centre d'intérêt
par le mot passion
était peut-être un mauvais choix
linguistique tout simplement.
Les mots ont un sens.
Ils renvoient à des images
et à des schémas de pensée,
qui fonctionnent malgré nous
dans notre cerveau.
Un mot plus neutre,
peut être un néologisme
ou un mot plus doux comme le mot
joie ou enthousiasme donc.
Serait peut-être moins oppressant,
moins complexant
quand on est à la recherche
de son propre alignement
et de ses propres centres d'intérêts.
- Même si c'est ma passion
d'avoir la vidéo finale,
c'est pas un moment,
où je vais être souriante
devant mon ordinateur
comme ça, genre :
J'adore ces rushes, c'est incroyable,
j'ai vraiment 20 heures de rush.
On va regarder ça dans la joie
et la bonne humeur.
Non il y a vraiment des phases
où c'est compliqué, c'est dur.
Et j'imagine que pareil,
comme les passionnés de sport.
Il y a des moments où physiquement
c'est fatigant, c'est éprouvant.
Mais on lâche rien,
parce qu'on veut aller jusqu'au bout.
Et même si on peut prendre l'exemple
du sport avec les compétitions,
mais ça doit être très pesant
et dur psychologiquement.
D'aller en compétition, voire perdre.
Mais tu le fais quand même,
parce que tu peux pas t'en empêcher.
- Je crois à l'enthousiasme racine.
A savoir qu'on a une sorte de
base d'intérêt pour quelque chose.
Et à partir de cette racine,
on va construire un tronc et des branches.
Moi je sais que cette passion
pour les histoires,
cette passion pour
la fabrication de mondes,
m'a amenée à voyager,
m'a amenée à m'intéresser
à l'histoire, aux civilisations,
m'a amenée à jouer
à pleins de jeux de stratégie.
Et j'ai tout construit autour de
ce premier intérêt étincelle, on va dire.
Je passe par exemple
à côté d'autres passions,
qui auraient pu me toucher
comme par exemple,
piloter des avions.
J'ai entièrement raté ce rendez-vous.
Ou jouer de la musique.
Je joue très bien de la musique,
mais je ne l'ai pas travaillé.
Donc c'est un talent qui
peu à peu a disparu, je pense.
Parce qu'une passion,
ça s'entretient.
Le fait que tous les jours
de 8h à 12h30, j'écrive des histoires.
ça n'a fait que renforcer mon plaisir,
et à les écrire et à les lire.
Je crois à la régularité,
à la progression.
C'est-à-dire une fois
qu'on a trouvé une passion,
il faut pas que
ça devienne une routine.
Il faut qu'on essaie tout le temps
d'aller un peu plus loin.
Dans mon travail d'écrivain,
j'essaie tout le temps
d'atteindre une sorte
de perfection selon mes critères,
qui consiste à faire
des mondes dans lesquels,
dès qu'on commence à mettre
un doigt dedans, on est aspiré.
C'est des mondes aspirants.
Des mondes, des romans univers,
dans lequel au bout d'un moment,
on oublie le réel
pour être dans cet univers là.
- Très intéressant,
la passion qui s'entretient,
l'enthousiasme racine.
Plus nous avançons
et plus je comprends moi aussi,
qu'une passion doit être entretenue.
Que le fait d'être enthousiaste,
ne veut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas
mettre de volonté dedans.
- En fait on utilise
notre passion au quotidien.
Et on a mis à profit notre passion
pour gagner notre vie,
mais en tout cas pour
nous épanouir au quotidien.
Parce que le travail
c'est 75% du temps.
Et en fait quand tu arrives à exploiter
ta passion à bon escient,
tu réponds, je pense,
à ta question intérieure.
Et t'es plus apaisé quoi.
Alors ça guérit pas tous les maux
de la terre d'avoir une passion.
Mais en vrai, ça soulage vachement.
- Une passion vient donc
ajouter quelque chose
ou soulager quelque chose
dans nos vies.
Ce qui veut donc dire
que l'on peut vivre sans passion,
mais pas sans enthousiasme.
Nous sommes forcément enthousiasmés
par des moments de notre vie.
C'est le fait ensuite,
de sortir de sa zone de confort
ou tout simplement
de construire de la régularité
dans l'expression de notre passion.
Qui l'intègre à nos vies et lui donne
de l'importance dans ses effets.
Et si j'analyse tout
ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui,
j'ai le sentiment que logiquement,
la passion matérialisée,
comme faire de la couture
ou collectionner des pin's.
Cache quelque chose de plus intime.
Alors on va creuser derrière la passion
pour voir ce qu'on peut y trouver.
Le point commun
de toutes mes discussions
a été de voir qu'il y avait disons :
Une sorte de fondement personnel
quasiment, de l'ordre de l'ADN
dans toutes les passions
de tous mes invités.
Quand je réfléchis,
je me dis que je suis passionné
par le mentalisme,
le cerveau, les casse-têtes,
pleins de choses comme ça.
Mais dans le fond, ce qui me plaît
m'intéresse vraiment,
c'est de savoir comment et pourquoi
fonctionnent les choses et les gens.
Ni plus ni moins.
Et ça, ça s'est matérialisé
par le mentalisme.
Mais le fait d'en avoir fait mon métier sur
scène, en vidéo, ou dans mes livres.
Vient surtout de ma curiosité à savoir
comment on monte un spectacle.
Comment fonctionne une vidéo,
comment on la produit.
Comment ça marche,
le fait d'écrire un livre.
Ce qui nous guide a l'air
donc d'être quasi génétique.
Et si ça ne l'est pas,
il y aurait fort à parier que ça
se développe très jeune chez nous.
De par des choses
qu'on rencontre dans notre vie
ou de par notre entourage.
- Je me souviens, j'ai des souvenirs
assez jeune vers 5-6 ans.
Où je me dis, je veux pas faire
comme les autres, je veux être original.
En fait, j'ai des souvenirs à six ans,
d'avoir des notions
et d'avoir compris l'idée d'originalité.
Voilà, ça cassait pas
trois pattes à un canard.
Mais de se dire :
"Ah je vois que tout le monde fait ça,
moi je vais faire un petit peu différent
à l'école, sur des petits trucs.
Mais proposer des idées
de jeu à la récré, etc.
Et il y avait toujours ce côté,
c'était assez naturel de dire :
Je vais aller un peu plus loin que
l'idée basique du petit jeu dans la cour.
Et venez on fait ça,
venez on rajoute cette petite règle, etc.
Et ça c'était assez...
En tout cas dans mes premiers
souvenirs de vie, je l'ai déjà.
- Moi, ce que je sens,
c'est que la passion
c'est une réponse à une question
qu'on n'arrive pas à formuler, pour moi.
Moi, pourquoi j'aime la musique ?
Pourquoi j'aime chanter ?
Pourquoi j'aime échanger
avec les gens ?
Bah parce qu'en fait,
je l'ai analysé il y a peu de temps.
Mais c'est que
quand j'étais adolescente,
je n'arrivais pas à exprimer
ce que je ressentais.
Qu'on m'interdisait
beaucoup de le dire.
Que dès que je disais quelque chose
au lycée ou au collège,
on me rabrouait.
Que du coup, j'ai créé un mécanisme
de défense dans l'humour, dans la blague.
Et les seuls moments où
je pouvais dire ce que je voulais.
Et où personne n'allait contre moi,
c'est quand je chantais.
Donc en fait, pour moi,
je dis souvent que chanter
c'est une deuxième langue.
C'est peut-être nul
et débile pour certains,
mais moi, c'est un vrai sens.
C'est que je ne serais sûrement pas
là où je suis maintenant,
si je n'avais pas eu la chanson.
Et si j'avais pas rencontré
ce canal d'échange,
pour m'apaiser quoi.
Et je crois qu'en fait depuis le début,
non pas que je mens.
Mais je crois que
ma plus grande passion,
c'est d'échanger.
En fait, c'est qu'en chantant,
je me sens comprise
dans une forme d'échange
qui est incroyable.
Et que moi,
je comprends tout à fait.
Et en fait, je crois que ce que j'aime
c'est le canal par lequel l'échange passe.
Moi c'est la musique,
mais je crois que j'aime encore plus
partager avec les gens en fait.
Et c'est pour ça
que j'ai fait des vidéos.
Et c'est pour ça que aussi
je fais de l'humour.
Et c'est pour ça que je suis
sur scène aussi en chantant.
Je crois que oui, peut-être
même avant la musique,
ma passion c'est les gens.
C'est nul mais c'est vrai, je crois.
- Mais c'est comme tout,
ça reprend la question de l'amour.
Est-ce qu'on peut aimer
plusieurs personnes ?
Est-ce que tu auras pas une passion,
qui sera quand même
au dessus des autres,
parce qu'elle est inconsciente,
elle vient de l'enfance,
elle te rappelle quelque chose,
il y a un affect.
C'était une passion que tu partageais
avec ton père ou ton grand-père.
Et à quel moment,
il y en a quand même une,
peut-être, qui est plus forte.
partager sa passion aussi,
c'est un truc hyper intéressant.
Comment on peut être sensible,
à un truc qui nous intéresse
pas du tout au début.
Et on rencontre un type
comme ça dans un bar,
qui va commencer à nous parler
d'une table en bois.
Et s'il nous raconte avec amour
et qu'il nous partage sa passion,
il y a une connexion qui se fait.
Parce que je m'en fou
des tables en bois,
mais tout d'un coup, la façon dont
il va partager son amour.
Et où je sens qu'on aura
un point commun,
parce que moi je voulais
parler de ma passion.
Et qu'en fait,
le simple fait
que deux personnes passionnées
se parlent de leurs passions.
Il y a quelque chose.
Alors qu'à la base, elles en ont
rien à foutre de l'un de l'autre,
mais il y a quelque chose quoi.
C'est du partage aussi la passion.
- Moi, je suis un surfer
d'où ce look de surfeur.
Et je dis tout le temps,
la vie c'est comme le surf.
Qu'est-ce qui est beau là dedans,
dans le surf ?
Vous devez remonter le tube.
C'est un peu un effort.
Mais de toute façon,
à un moment donné,
vous attendez la vague.
Et il y a la plupart des gens,
80% des gens.
Ils sont dans la métaphore,
ils se retournent vers les gens et font :
"Elle est bien la vague qui arrive là ?
Elle est bien là ?
Tu crois que je la prends celle-là ?"
Non, vous la prenez.
Et puis qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
Vous allez tomber,
vous allez tomber dans l'eau.
Mais vous vous serez amusé.
- C'est pas juste une notion de temps
et de difficulté et qu'on lâche pas.
Il y a quand même un truc
où au fond de toi, tu vibres pour ça.
- Je crois que derrière
beaucoup d'enthousiasme,
il y a la compensation d'une blessure.
C'est parce que j'étais pas
très bon élève à l'école.
C'est parce que
j'étais pas très sociable.
Que les univers fantastiques que
me racontait mon père en mythologie,
me touchaient autant.
C'est parce qu'aussi,
j'étais un peu solitaire à l'école.
Que le fait de raconter des histoires,
m'apportait autant.
Et au fur et à mesure que ce monde
me semblait un monde étranger
et dans lequel, j'aurais
des difficultés à m'insérer.
Le plaisir d'être dans
des mondes artificiels,
avec des règles différentes
me touchait.
L'idée de par exemple,
quand j'ai joué à civilisation,
de fabriquer des civilisations.
C'était en fait une volonté
de refaire un monde meilleur
que celui dans lequel
je me trouvais.
Parce que dans ce monde,
j'étais pas bien.
Je me disais,
je vais essayer de faire mieux.
- On peut donc conclure
beaucoup de choses sur la passion.
Déjà, je suis ravi d'avoir
eu toutes ces personnes
qui sont reconnues pour ce que
nous pensons être leurs passions.
Mais qui ont dévoilé le derrière
de leurs sentiments vis-à-vis de ça.
D'ailleurs, avant de passer à la suite,
je vais prendre 10 secondes pour remercier
tous les intervenants de cette vidéo.
Les chaînes YouTube de Pierre Croce,
Benjamin Verrecchia, PADG,
Lola Dubini, Natoo,
sont en lien dans la description.
Je vous invite
à aller les voir évidemment.
Comme tous les mondes que
Bernard Werber a créé dans ses livres,
je vous mets également
le lien description.
Leurs témoignages à tous
ont été précieux
pour mieux comprendre la passion.
Ils ont parlé sans filtre d'une partie
assez intime de leur vie.
Donc merci à eux, beaucoup.
Merci également à Disney
de m'avoir proposé ce partenariat.
Et de m'avoir aidé à monter
ce sujet autour de la passion
et autour de l'histoire de Joe Gartner.
Je vous invite vraiment
à regarder Soul,
où vous découvrirez
le point de vue de Joe et de 22.
Le film d'animation
est aussi cool à regarder,
que fort dans
les questions qu'il soulève.
Soul est dispo depuis
le 25 décembre en streaming
exclusivement sur Disney +.
Vous avez le lien dans la description.
En conclusion,
ces passions enthousiasmantes.
C'est un petit compromis d'appellation.
Se placent en supplément dans nos vies,
en supplément de quelque chose.
Elles sont souvent l'expression
des choses plus profondes chez nous.
Et peuvent aussi être changeantes.
Elles ne sont pas forcément figées.
Un peu comme si on pouvait
utiliser des miroirs différents,
pour envoyer le même reflet
d'une personne.
C'est peut-être pour ça que l'on a parfois
du mal à trouver sa passion visible.
Mais ça veut pas dire pour autant,
qu'on n'a pas une passion profonde,
plus générale, plus large qui représente
un trait de caractère chez nous.
Ou qui représente simplement
une envie ou un but.
Les passions qui sont
de l'ordre de l'activité,
ne sont alors durable dans le temps
que si on le décide.
Paradoxalement,
ça demande une régularité,
une sorte d'effort à fournir,
parfois des compromis.
Pour que cette occupation devienne
durable vraiment dans le temps
et qu'elle s'ancre dans nos vies.
Et puis, il faut aussi oser découvrir
de nouveaux territoires au sens figuré,
dans nos vies,
pour rencontrer ce qui va
nous enthousiasmer vraiment.
Alors soyez curieux.
Soyez curieux, parce qu'au final,
exprimer qui on est
au travers d'une passion,
ça changera pas le monde.
Mais ça transformera
peut-être le vôtre.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !